ich höre dich nur ich komme nicht mit
ihnen nie wo bist du
ich bin im dunkeln sie selber nicht
scheiße nochmal verklage ich höre doch
nicht ich hab dich da bist du ja wo wir
die rettung da rein
da reißt sie dazu das war richtig heftig
das pendel okay was ich jetzt erstmal
die portale inside in die höhle zurück
naja ok dann 40 in der kiste
ich komme ins bett du musst hier nochmal
lernst du zu machen und kulig die nach
langer schlaf schön bis ende ist in der
zweiten folge doch super lassen 2
minuten raus jetzt ist egal okay wie
schneidet es einfach jede folge zehn
minuten passiert noch keine flaschen
keine komischen und auf stimmigkeit so
ich werde portugals aber mit dem portal
im inneren anderen würde da hinten
setzen
dann nehmen sie ruhig mit walter das lag
bei mir ich durchschnittlich immer so
viel durchschnittlich nicht es
zwischenzeitlich
durchsichtig ich habe kaum noch mal fünf
schwert oder sogar zum start unserer
hier so schwer
ja also ich muss jetzt sagen ich habe in
dieser folge der letzten folge habe ich
richtig was geschafft hab ne kuh in akk
im gefängnis eingesperrt habe ich mit
portugal befreit ich bin richtig stolz
auf sich selbst oder so ich frostig
die sticks ich habe das wie holz mehr
ich brauche was das ist
hallo berta dass berta roberto hallo
peter wir suchen jetzt auch bertram für
dich jetzt hoch und bertram
der wochensieger hey hey hey bis mit
komplizen hasenkopf echten hasen erfolgt
per tram und berta ganz wichtig ist
nicht nur platz ab um die letzten guten
käfig dahin zu setzen deswegen warst du
kannst du was zu essen haben hier aber
ich muss ganz kurz jetzt ganz ganz kurz
muss ich muss ich jetzt noch eben stieg
weiter doch etwas vernünftiges zu
fressen hier trotz robert ragge auf den
weg okay das wäre seine ruhe
verdammt erhitzen dass das gehege
na ja genau ich finde das soll auch so
sein
hier sind richtig viele kühe und stellt
sich damit einer kuh so doofe komm her
komm her ja er kommt er kommt
so passen auch als freund was jetzt
passiert ist nötig
ich hab so abstrakt abzuschließen eilig
wird richtig gerne wir brauchen auf
jeden fall eine schweinefarm doku fahren
kümmert sich darum kümmere ich mich vom
ok dann kümmere ich mich um oxidieren
und links machen
naja der haut ab haut ab übrigens fragen
ja auch immer noch leute hey wann fangt
ihr denn endlich an mit wie zivis ist
doch gar nicht richtig lief ideal wäre
noch gesagt dass wir das nachher machen
werden nach euren ganzen tipps wir
machen es übrigens auch schon in den
beiden bisschen aus wir müssen
allerdings haben haben wir gesagt dass
wir das ganze als display machen wollten
allerdings hat mit einem netz playern
sich bisschen langweilig hast du einfach
fiete wies motiv platz drei nimmt dann
hat man ein paar mehr möglichkeiten neue
atome wir wollen uns gar nicht so viel
damit beschäftigen
und ich finde allgemein und später ins
spiel schon im späteren spiel schon aber
allein diese ganzen sachen jetzt wo ich
hingucke diese ganzen neuen die ohne die
dazugekommen sind es schon riesen
ansporn und die portugals das ist ja
alles gut zu wissen dass eine allergie
gar nicht also wir beschäftigen uns
schon damit allerdings halt auch so
unterschwellig so ein bisschen so ihr
beide ihr wert jetzt gefallen aber vorm
mund heraus welche bestehen bleibt drin
so gut verkauft dass meine waypoint
ziehen wie weg sind warum weil wir das
auf dem server neu gemacht haben für
klar wenn du die map map umgezogen okay
ihr beide seid echt süß und ihr kriegt
ihr was zu essen
sie leben sich ich muss ein screenshot
machen
wo waren jetzt noch mal die andere nein
ich hab ich hab mich vertan
jetzt muss ich mitten durch den
dschungel durchlauf oder wie bei gold
zum möglichen portugal mit manchmal kann
es mal gleich gucken welches portal bei
uns im haus ist glauben ist irgendeine
religion bezogen wenn dir sicher wissen
wo ich bin sogar ohne also wenn ich ihm
wissen wen ich sage das ist einfach nur
rechte teil fertig bin von schule
training etc
ich kann ich gar nicht mehr na gut aber
hier sollen so ein komisches allerdings
muss ich nehme es einfach mal
ich werde jetzt einmal mit diesen bombay
ich finde das holz einfach so richtig
geil ich würd sagen dass ersetzen wir
mit dem holz wieder zu hause haben bei
uns daher an den an den fehlern das
werber holz ja ich mal eine nachricht
ich rappe holz und heißes thema holz was
ich schon mal eine graue wie das war ja
ich schon mal es heißt what can produce
750 euro
aber egal wozu gibts die kommentare
schreibt funktion nein das glaube ich
nicht ausquatschen also eure tipps sind
einmal herzlich willkommen herzlich
willkommen
herzlich willkommen
ist scheißegal der feier bis alles
zerfällt
geht das wirklich so ja ja wenn sie mir
das sagt dann ist das so ist so ruhig
gefallen vielleicht schreiben uns ein
kommentar an unser lieblingswort ist
derweil seine sagen jetzt gar nicht so
oft manchmal ich sage dir wie oft derbe
ist es richtig derbe von jetzt erstmal
ein paar ausklappen basler karte fällt
hier das ist wer was uns im haus nicht
wieder raus ich nenne sie fledermaus
krediten richtig einfallsreichen habe
jetzt die fledermäuse land das natürlich
viel viel viel kreativer die
einfallsreiche innovativer viel
umfangreicher viel gestalterische viel
besser er will sein wortschatz strom von
galeria baarer man ich finde die höhle
nicht mehr ich bin total bescheuert ich
finde aber so viele kühlen erklärung was
seine hast dann ist es erst einmal wer
noch alles darüber gold ja aber da waren
lover see und nun ziemlich direkt du
hast jetzt für die holde luftfilter und
die rezession als höhle durch den
dschungel da hinten
ja du bist alt durch den dschungel
gelaufen ich bin aber schon da ist eine
schlucht
wie auch jetzt nämlich wollte allgemein
einfach ein lover see und vielleicht
noch ein bisschen trainieren abgreifen
ich mal unsere bauern fahren hier ist
geil serie die leute trauen ihm
geschildert haben muss das jetzt schon
ein richtig geiles stück ding sein
geil geil das erz haben wir es etwas
ganz besonderes
sodann gucken am besten noch mal ganz
kurz nach welches links in der bei uns
zu hause ist welches was ja welches
portal
zudem gesagt habe ich nochmal moment
gelb gelbes portal und weißt du wie du
ein games wie oft ein rot blaues machst
auf der realität ist es hier angezeigt
machst du ein gelb ist es bei uns zu
hause gelten darf sich direkt über auf
das drücken sonst durch die rechte
maustaste nämlich weg wir feiern bis
alles zerfällt gemacht hätte ich würde
nicht mehr
ich bin am hacken ich bin hackl
hackedicht bin am hackl nach takt
passend zum thema karneval conny
amerikaner weiß pause einlegt hat es
sich was für dich gut dass wir eine
kleine pause eingelegt akustisch spaß
mehr ich möchte da nicht näher darauf
eingehen
grandi möchte nicht darüber reden es
muss also ein großer spaß krach dann
würde ich die sprache hier so unsere
komplette beendet ich finde ich finde
ich nie mehr das ist richtig heftig
richtig wohl einfach nur unsere
komplette baum fahren
im wald verlaufen ist auf